acusaciones cruzadas las versiones sobre
la crisis migratoria entre belarús y la
unión europea entran de nuevo en disputa
los europeos acusan a belarús de avivar
la migración hacia el bloque
el régimen de lukashenko ha comenzado a
comportarse como régimen mafioso y las
sanciones los está viviendo y ellos no
saben qué más hacer entonces tratan de
socavar a la unión europea atacando y
lanzando ataques mixtos contra los
estados miembros del bloque una de
recriminaciones que reafirman las del
gobierno polaco que subió el tono
acusando a rusia de estar detrás de la
crisis lukashenko es el ejecutor del
último ataque pero este tiene un
patrocinador que está en moscú y es el
presidente putin este ataque muestra su
determinación de llevar a cabo el
escenario de la reconstrucción del
imperio ruso por su parte lukashenko
calificó como un intento de intimidación
el traslado de miles de tropas polacas a
la frontera entre los países vecinos se
vuelve no soy un loco y entiendo muy
bien a que puede conducir esto entonces
no hay valor aquí agarrar un rifle de
asalto y marchar hacia la frontera
polaca por cierto un lugar donde solía
servir como guardia fronterizo no seguro
que no nos damos cuenta conocíamos
nuestro lugar pero no no nos
arrodillaremos
en medio de las disputas miles de
migrantes se concentran frente a los
alambres de púas que ahora dividen la
frontera entre polonia y belarús la
unión europea ha anunciado en repetidas
ocasiones las intenciones de lukashenko
de poner en riesgo la seguridad del
bloque al alentar la migración irregular
por lo tanto el bloque amenaza con
nuevas sanciones